what's up guys had no freaking clue this
was gonna be happening today apparently
spider-man no way home crap happened
with entertainment weekly today marvel's
trying to ship some stuff in there
before dc fandom this weekend you best
bet we're gonna be covering stuff where
we got a special little video prep for
you guys you'll see you'll see obviously
we've got to see what spider-mart has to
say about what they talked about here
we're not going to read the article
ourselves is that right warren is that
right that's why we're having a package
shipped here this weekend
that's the exchange he ships a package
once in a while that he can pick up here
when he visits la
we get to react to all his videos
the price of being a storage
space what's going on everybody it's
warren welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and mcu
and today is a great day because we have
some new official photos from spiderman
no way home and we have tom holland
himself talking about some scenes in the
movie what it was like filming some of
these scenes one scene in particular the
scene with doc ock alfred molina
returning to play the character what
that was like and what it was like
filming with zendaya and jacob battle on
again and the heartbreak that they all
felt not knowing if this actually was
going to be the last spider-man film
that they filmed together and last but
not least tom holland talks about if
they did do another spider-man film or
franchise after the no way home trilogy
it would have to be very different than
what they are doing now let's get one
thing out of the way this is not the
last time he's gonna be spider-man
that's just ridiculous yes there might
be some time in between spider-man
stand-alone films this is not the last
time we're going to see him with
spider-man
you know how we all know did you not
hear about that venom post-credits scene
yeah what pretty glitching piece of
evidence
freaking compound that would be if that
was the last time we see tom holland's
spider-man no way over there you just
make that post currency and then you're
like oh wait a minute
whoops i i guess we we won't ever see
that happen but hey it was a fun idea
while last year right that's just yeah
come on dad there's no way i can't buy
that for one second first and foremost
this is all coming from
entertainmentweekly.ew.com and they
that's a flattering photo of sunday
spiderman nowhere
sure of spider-man and mj now if you pay
kind of for
attention to mj's clothes and spider-man
spidey suit you can notice that these
are actually the exact same outfits that
they were wearing at the end of
spider-man far from home in the
post-credits scene so this picture that
we're looking at right here is most
likely at the very beginning of the film
it's no doubt going to take place right
after the events of spider-man fire from
home right after mysterio reveals that
peter parker is spider-man this is most
likely right after jjj gets done talking
about her hair
and everybody's going to turn and look
at spider-man and then he's going to
grab mj and get out of there and as we
know from the post-credits scene mj did
not really like web slinging that much
and in this one it looks like he's free
falling for some period of time before
he slings that web and she just looks
like she's having a great time now the
next i don't know about that man
we get another photo of spiderman doctor
strange what appears to be right out
look how pissed he looks
just looks really fed up with peter like
come on kid what are you doing here and
if you notice he is still wearing that
red and black spider-man suit so this
most likely is taking place during the
first half of the film as well this is
probably either right before or right
after he goes to doctor strange and asks
him to do that spell where everybody can
forget that peter parker is spider-man
it's actually making me question the
structure of it because of the suit as
we've seen the trailer you know the
place is all snowed out he's all in his
winter outfit uh doctor strange peter
parker shows up not a spider-man but
just as peter parker this has to
probably be he i'm assuming he maybe
visits dr strange first or maybe just
lands in front of him at one point he's
trying to escape and they have just a
little tease that dr strange will be
coming back in the movie 20 minutes
later or something like that he's just
annoyed that peter dent at the top of
the station wagon now there's absolutely
zero context to these photos however if
i look at this photo with spider-man and
doctor strange i kind of feel like it's
a very particular scene i kind of feel
like this is right after some villains
are let loose and the multiverse kind of
starts to go in the chaos since we see
peter parker in normal clothes in the
trailer inside of the sanctum asking
doctor strange to do the spell and in
this photo he is in his spider-man
outfit i want to say that this is after
doctor strange does the spell also not
to mention wong is nowhere to be seen
and if something was going on outside
wong would definitely be there checking
it out so i'm assuming like anything
post spell has the original strange
costume that spider-man kind of messes
up the spell or as dr strange says he
tampers with it and now it looks like
that tampering kind of caused things to
go wrong and now they're dealing with
the repercussions and this could be why
doctor strange is pretty fed up with
spider-man in this photo his arms are
crossed and he's looking at him kind of
like you see what you did kid also at
this point we kind of know that the
villains are going to be kept inside of
a magical prison cell inside of the
sanctum that strange is holding them in
and as rumor has it spider-man is
actually going to let these villains
free whether on purpose or accident or
whether it was with the spell we don't
know at this point but that could be
what we're seeing right here he let all
of the villains go and that could be the
reason that strange is pretty pissed
right here hopefully we'll find out a
little bit more when that trailer comes
and hopefully we're getting that within
about a month now is he saying the
photos are from the same moment as when
jay jonah jameson like reveals a
mentalist cause he's saying that photo
with dr strange would be probably after
then after the spell yeah after the
spell is broken and then they're looking
outside and all the chaos going wrong
yeah so him and mj are zipping away from
the j jones james and chaos and then
here on top of the car is after the
spell there's got to be more to how the
spell went wrong because if doctor
strange really is that upset at peter
over it then i'm like dude it's not
entirely peter's fault you know the
invisibility here too
you have a major contribution to what
went wrong here you can't just blame
peter they're like look what you did oh
that's right this could be from right
before the fight scene where doctor
strange pushes him out of his body yeah
that actually makes more sense i don't
know why i might jump to the other thing
first but with these photos like i
mentioned came interviews with tom
holland and him speaking up about some
certain parts of the film and the first
thing we're going to talk about is his
scene with alfred molina tom holland
talks about filming with alfred molina
and keep in mind the last time that
alfred molina filmed as doc ock was in
2004. that's when spider-man 2 came out
which also looks like
2003 as well here's what tom holland had
to say about filming with alfred molina
he said it was really fun to watch him
see how technology has advanced when he
was making these films the arms were
puppets and when we did it they're all
imaginary and cg it was quite cool to
see him relive it but also relearn it
also doesn't get me more excited it
doesn't
really great yeah
and it makes it so much more tangible
yeah it makes it so much cooler more
believable when they were puppets i got
that scene but he's still unconscious in
the surgery room and they're like
killing all the the nurses and surgeons
and all that yeah that was a fantastic
scene i don't know if it's cgi you could
just tell in cgf you could do anything
with cgi so it's just not as magical as
knowing they were right there
obviously there was some cgi in
spider-man 2 with the arms right there's
no denying that we're not dumb asses
well there's an argument he made for
that we are not naive to the fact that
there was cgi in there i'm just saying
that the fact that there was no puppets
is a bit of a letdown it sounds like the
future of spider-man is kind of unknown
at this point and no way home could be
it for tom holland now i seriously doubt
that he loves playing the character and
marvel loves him and sony loves him and
they have a great relationship now and i
don't think that's coming to an end
anytime soon okay here's kind of how i
feel that i think with especially the
anticipation a desire excitement at the
prospect of toby and andrew coming into
the spider-man franchise again if
there's anything that's made really
clear you can do another iron man
without robert downey jr but it's a bit
of a challenge it can be difficult to do
that with a bunch of other comfort
characters because of the fact of the
celebrity association to them that
you're like oh man it'd be hard to
switch them out we need them the
students like we need them to play them
i feel like with spider-man though like
tom holland needs spider-man a lot more
than they need soft clearly
you can change a spider-man you can
interchange them and i don't feel people
are as personally married to tom holland
as they are for possibly some other
characters i know it's going to offend
some people but come on you can just see
why people are erupting in excitement
over the idea of the other spider-man
being in here and that's not to say that
they don't like tom holland that's only
to say that clearly
you can you can replace a spiderman
so to cap it off tom hall and stick it
around in this article he's leading us
to believe like he doesn't know what's
going to happen next he said we were all
treating no way home as the end of a
franchise let's say i think if we're
lucky enough to dive into these
characters again you'd be seeing a very
different version it would no longer be
the homecoming trilogy we would give it
some time and try to build something
different and tonally change the films
whether that happens or not i don't know
but we were definitely treating no way
home like it was coming to an end and it
felt like it he goes on to say we've
been making these films for five years
now we've had such an amazing
relationship the three of us we've been
with each other every step of the way
obviously talking about zendaya and
jacob babylon and himself he continues
to say we've done every single film
every single press tour so this one
scene we didn't know if this would be
the last time we were all working
together it was heartbreaking but also
really exciting because we're all moving
into the next chapter of our careers so
sharing that moment with them was maybe
the best day i've ever had on set i
don't think i've ever cried like that
ever but in the article for
entertainment weekly it says still tom
holland adds that just because he's
spent the last five years perfecting his
web singing didn't mean that he could
let himself get complacent tom holland
said if you're not willing to focus and
do the prep work you're going to get
called out because when you're dealing
with magical spells and dimensions it
really gets complicated now when tom
holland talks about the end of the
homecoming franchise and trilogy i think
that's exactly what he's talking about
the end of the homecoming trilogy and if
this truly is the last time that we're
going to see tom holland on screen i
think it's actually going to be really
really cool to not only see him but see
the spider-man that came before him him
standing right next to toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man and then at the end standing
right next to mj and ned i don't think
this is the last time we'll see tom hall
into spider-man but i do think that
there will probably be some time in
between spider-man films after this and
i do think that this film is going to be
truly truly epic but let me know what
you think about all of this in the
comments down below what do you think
about these new photos and what do you
think about what tom holland said about
this possibly being the end leave all
your thoughts comments hopes dreams
tears in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter i did post these
photos on their first so if you want to
stay up to date live follow me there and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
i unfollowed you over there man i didn't
like what you were having to say about
me publicly all right guys
subscribe to cosmic wonder you subscribe
to us here that second trailer is right
around the corner we got some time i got
some time that's really something during
dc fandom that was a shadow the whole
event boss move
all right guys we'll see